welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 14
and we're gonna learn how you can
network like a billionaire
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
warren is probably the most rational
person i've ever met
charlie munger would be a close rival
and charlie became a man that warren
depended on
heavily and i think his first
experiences in the discarded cigar but
era
convinced them that it was not exactly
where he wanted to be
he'd made so much money for so long
doing what he'd been taught by ben
graham
which should buy these very cheap stocks
if they were cheap enough he didn't care
it was a lousy company in a lousy
management he knew he was going to make
money anyway just because of the
cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices
rather than fair companies at wonderful
prices and that was enormously important
because it enabled berkshire to scale up
in a way that would have been impossible
to do otherwise we were metal partners
right from the moment we met i want to
know
going back 50 years what it was like
when you first met warren
well i thought he was a prodigy and i
got a lot of criticism my wife said
why are you paying such enormous respect
to that young man with a crew cut
who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense
important ideas into just a very few
words
if you're not interested in the economic
scene right now
you're mentally dead charlie has no tax
all right let's talk a little bit about
bankers charlie on friday compared them
to heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful charlie but i
would not have chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility
he didn't get his fair share the ideal
way to run a headquarters is to have
one man preferably over 80
sitting in an office by himself
[Music]
anything else is pure flippery
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listen to him
[Music]
[Applause]
we never had an argument we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what the hell difference does it make to
me
[Applause]
net the record is working out fine i
work with great group of people that
make my life
very easy and take good care of me
we have 25 people in the office and
if you go back it's the exact same 25
the exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire we don't have a public
relations department investor relations
we don't have a general counsel
we don't have a human relations
department we just don't go for anything
that
people do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life i like and
it's not work to me it's just a form of
play basically
[Music]
to go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956
that berkshire came out of there were
seven people sitting there at a table
having dinner relatives primarily and i
said here's the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little half page
what i call the ground rules and i want
you to read these
and if you feel okay about that about
the interaction
what the expectations are and all of
that sort of thing then we'll join
forces
and if you don't it's fine other people
have you know but we don't we shouldn't
be partners i mean
you know if i'm gonna have a partnership
with somebody i want to be compatible it
is
you know and when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that
so by my actions and my communications
and everything
i want to attract the people that from
the public market that i want
and i want to keep the others away
costco was built
sal price who started the price club
that thing he sat down and figured out
the customer he didn't want
and he set up a system that would keep
away the customer he didn't want who did
not want he didn't want somebody buying
a quart of milk with somebody behind
them with a
with a basket of 200 worth of goods
waiting for that
so we put in a membership fee and by
putting in a membership page
he killed all the drop in business the
business to belong to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire to to keep out people
who have expectations
about us that are different than ours i
mean good for them and i hope they find
somebody they said
but if you're going to run a church you
want
you want your seats to be filled by
people that are generally want to
listen to your form of religion and you
don't want it to change every week and
say gee i need a new group and i'll go
out and talk to a bunch of investors and
get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church
there's a million 645 000 or so
a equivalent shares and those are the
seats and i want them occupied by people
that are on the same page i am i always
kind of like
i get a little upset whenever any media
attention
focuses on me personally and me leaving
facebook
much less a movie it's been it's been
kind of a bad year
hasn't it it turned out okay time
academy
it turned out it turned out it turned
out good the time thing was awesome um
the um that was those really flattering
but like
but i think that it's one of these
things that the media systematically
gets
wrong is that this idea that it's a
person right it's never a person
right it's always a team and the most
important thing if you
are an entrepreneur trying to build
something is you need to build a really
good team and that's what i spend a lot
of my time on right i mean i spend
um probably at least three hours a day
with our core team
right at doing things i spend probably
25 percent of my time recruiting finding
good people
both outside the company and inside the
company to put in more
and more um impactful roles i don't hire
people who i wouldn't work for
myself i think that's a really good
heuristic because everyone knows this
like there's the saying like
a players hire a players and b players
hire c
players which is like good people higher
good yeah um
and i don't think that that's that
informative right because i mean what
are you gonna say like to someone in
your organization's higher better
player you don't get to hire people like
i mean no i mean um
and i think a lot of the time the
problem is you don't actually know and
sometimes you're like
trying to figure out how good someone is
if you didn't think they were good you
wouldn't have hired them
but the heuristic of only hiring people
who you would work for
um tends to be pretty good i think
because then it's like then that you
know right it's like i would not work
for this person then okay i'm not gonna
like
stretch just because i need to fill a
role today one definition that i have
for uh
a good team is a group of people that
makes better decisions as a whole
than it would individually make is a sum
of the parts and
when you're i think most smart people
like learning
right and i mean that's like one of the
thrills of starting a company right is
you're just
the learning curve can be so steep and
if you can set up a team dynamic
where you're constantly learning from
the people around you then i mean what's
better
right so these are the people i wake up
every morning and i wanna i wanna go
learn from and work from is that one of
your heuristics for hiring people too
to like hire people that you learn from
yeah
uh and when building a team you want it
to you want to think about the dynamics
so that way
you can maintain this property that the
team makes better decisions
as a group than any individual would you
need a team
around you to deliver a lot of idea how
do you choose your team
based on what
well um i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else
so when i interview somebody
my interview question is always the same
it's just
i said tell me the story of your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
if and and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on
and how you solved them and
that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck i think it's the
very rare idea that can be done by a
single individual
almost everything that is going to
change the world solve a problem
improve something these are usually big
efforts and they require
you know teams a team working together
to really get something important done
and that has been the story of
amazon.com at every step along the way
we've had a team here that is
is making this work i mean i don't know
even even at the smallest scale
you have to figure out how to get help
from your friends from your family
members
uh from uh people that you can hire in
those early days
i think without that it would never work
i find if i'm
stressed about something it's usually
because
i'm not doing anything about it and so
if i'm stressed
about something i'm trying to figure out
why am i stressed i'm listening to my
body
as a signal that i'm that something is
awry and then i find that the stress
goes away
the second i take the first step of you
know identify the source of the stress
why am i stressed about this
what's going on and then you know talk
to somebody about it
find you know find allies um you know i
would say that
uh if you can find friends
who are interested in similar things or
want to help you solve a problem
problem solving is um is
inspiring for me all by itself i have as
long as i have
allies there's nothing more fun than
getting in a room
with a group of inventors
and saying look here's the problem let's
invent a solution to it
and as soon as you start doing that i
find that it turns from
something that might create stress into
something that
creates fun how do you stay fresh and
how have you like what can you attribute
staying in
the business for so long i think every
year you're trying to reinvent yourself
and you stay
in touch with what other people are
doing thinking feeling
i have always felt that my instinct and
ability to connect with the audience was
what carried us
every day after the show now i do
something called after the show which
airs on oxygen
i have spent for the past 16 years
um a half an hour an hour
just talking to people so all my
audience comes from a cross section
around the country
so i get i stay connected to what peop
real people are thinking and doing and
want
i think the most important is knowing
your strengths
and weaknesses and knowing what you
enjoy doing you know if you look at it
as a job you've already lost
it it's not going to be your passion and
you're going to count the hours if
you look at it as as something you love
to do
um and then you know what your strengths
are
then you can leverage those strengths in
in your business and in helping others
and
once you recognize your weaknesses then
you can work with people that complement
you
i mean every one of my businesses i've
had a partner
who's very anal martin woodall
todd wagner i mean incredibly anal
people
perfectionist because i'm a slob you
know i'm i'm a big picture think about
what's around the corner
how's technology going to change things
how can i change you know this industry
and you know making sure that there's
somebody there to make to dot the eyes
cross the t's and
keep me in the baselines um and
you know recognizing my weaknesses is
just as important as
recognizing my strengths and my core
competencies and and
you know having a passion to do treating
people equally is not
is not the same is not recognizing who
they truly are
and taking advantage of their skills you
know and
i've learned that through sin i've
learned that through all this and
you know like sin and i talk we'll be a
much better organization i'll be a
better exec i'll be a better investor
i'll be a better
um shark um because i recognize that
you know treating people equally is not
the same as treating them
recognizing their skills and their
differences and for this for this
audience
it's critically important you know
and i think there's an opportunity now
and i know hopefully
you know people like me will recognize
that the old white guys now
newly old white guys that are in
positions of power
that there are things that you can do
that i can't do that there are things
you see
that i don't see there are opportunities
that you can create
that i can't create you know we were
trying to sell
to the black community through the mavs
with multiple white men we were trying
to sell to moms
with multiple white men it's not that
they're not capable
it's not that they're not skilled it's
just everybody brings
something different to the table and as
an entrepreneur
you have to recognize what the
differences are that you bring to the
table and you have to be brutally honest
with yourself
right you can't lie to yourself like we
all lie to ourselves as entrepreneurs
but those differences can be part of
your unique skill set like i talked
about earlier
and now i'm finally starting to
recognize those things
and you know the one thing i know it's
going to make me a load more money
when microsoft my early partner was paul
allen and then steve ballmer
was my partner now melinda's uh you know
even
a totally equal partner in all the
foundation work we're doing
so she she and i run it together it was
so fascinating i mean the relationships
we were building
learning all this new stuff to have
somebody to brainstorm with about it
uh you know made it a lot more fun
you know things like writing letters
together giving speeches together we had
to learn
how to bring out the best of the both of
us and in doing those things but yeah it
was always you know clear we wanted to
do it together
you have to be thoughtful about creating
an environment where new ideas of
innovation
are not only welcome but they're
encouraged they're embraced
and the success of them are trumpeted
sure because otherwise you you have the
risk of
like all things you know the complacency
factor you know leads you
lead you down a narrowing road of
opportunity
and look i face it with my own firm now
18 years
you know 17 going on 18 years in in the
making
of how do we make sure we don't atrophy
on what we were good at and oh by the
way
how do we ensure that we continue to to
evolve
our culture on the one hand and and
and expand our business opportunities in
the markets that we're in
building a team is the hardest thing for
an entrepreneur to do
because very often they don't know what
they don't know
right they they know their area of
specialty really well
but other areas they think they
understand but they don't
and every area is more complex and more
nuanced
than it appears to somebody you know to
i see
so many entrepreneurs who think
marketing is about
a press release or an advertising
campaign it's not
it's much more nuanced and sophisticated
than that
so team building is very important
some entrepreneurs do a really good job
of growing
larry page is an example mark zuckerberg
is an example of
being better at new functions as they
come up
uh ins
and and and also they've done a really
good job of
adding people who they can learn these
new areas from
uh what i find is some entrepreneurs
assume they know the answer
and that's very dangerous and others
know they don't know
and they hire the people who they can
learn from
but they can still apply their
entrepreneurial style in these new areas
sometimes it makes sense for the
entrepreneur to keep being ceo and
driving the whole vision
usually that's the best course but some
entrepreneurs can't think broadly enough
to do that
and they can't grow fast enough trust is
the
most important thing as we discussed
this a few minutes ago
if people give me when i had no money
because when alibaba started
18 founders in my apartment i told
everybody say
put your all your money savings on the
table
leaving the money
for for 10 miles food and
room you know rent what's that
the money you have put on the table i
want to gather the money
and nobody should borrow the money from
parents nobody should borrow money from
friends
because i don't want to make your
parents and friends bankrupt because
doing alibaba
so 18 people we gathered
50 000 us dollars we studied alibaba
in my apartment and those people
actually none of us have money but if if
somebody say i give you 1 million u.s
dollars
and i give you trust which one i would
choose
i choose those people who give me the
trust
because it's the trust that make make
us be united it's the truth
i think 18 founders they trust me
because they trust me i have to be very
loyalty
to them and loyal to the mission that uh
that we have i think a lot of
entrepreneurship know that
i hate people work for me i want to
people work for the mission that we
agreed together
because you don't want people work for
me because people like me
when i look when i look further this
guy's a handsome wayne get closer he's
so ugly
everybody in the world the same you
should not get closer
further is good so you think a jack is
great but you know if you get closer
not necessarily i'll be angry i will
happy i'm happy i got
but when people trusting you
that's the most valuable things i think
later when we got our event
venture capitalists invested us the
thing
they noticed is that because my team
trust me and i trust my teams
in the early days i mean as an
entrepreneur you're every department
so uh i was the before and after butt
model literally
i took a picture of my own butt took it
to kinko's got it laminated
with and without spanx on stood in the
stores and i'm like
hey look what this can do for you um i
was
i was like the packer and shipper i was
the head of sales i was everything and
you learn very quickly what you're good
at and what you're not good at and what
you enjoy and what you don't enjoy and
there's usually a correlation between
the two
and so i often say as soon as you can
afford to hire your weaknesses
and a few years into spanx it was
abundantly clear that the lane that i
needed to stay in was inventing
selling promoting spanx actually is
never advertised
spanx is 18 years old and the first time
we've ever even
sampled an ad was to uh in 16.
and so i was sort of the the
advertisement and
and me being out in the field talking
about the product
and sharing the story of the why why
we're making this why it's better
was a big part of the formula and i
needed someone to be
in the company day-to-day running the
daily operations
what are the three things you're looking
to entrepreneur do you look at the idea
or do you look at the person
well it's almost a cliche but vcs talk
about team team team team team
and team does not mean credibility
that's a mistake that's a misconception
team means do we think this team can
actually
execute the vision and
do we think this team can create
a compelling vision because oftentimes
the vision that they initially present
doesn't end up being the business that
they create
so is there someone on the team who's a
visionary who's agile and nimble
and can come up with lots of ideas is
there someone on the team who's a great
engineering leader
who can recruit a lot of engineers is
there a great core technologist
who can build you know the initial
initial technology
he's like a real hardcore developer is
there someone on the team who can watch
over the business
do deals basically relieve all the other
people of that burden
of having to go and hire people and deal
with human resources and
operate the company and deal with legal
and so forth and in every company the
balance is different
but you have to get a complete team and
so most of the companies we see
we don't even get past the first meeting
because we we can see so clearly
that their team is missing certain uh
critical pieces
i'd get comfort and nurture from them
when i failed that's not what you need
you need to expand your network when i
was getting comfort from the people that
loved me
and accepted me as i was i should have
been expanding my network by investing
in conferences
summits and masterminds to get access to
the way other people think the way other
people operate
and to their success so i could learn
from them
and possibly as importantly with the
network you get to collaborate with
other people
my business is kind of different i own a
hair salon
and i have started a brand for myself
and probably went about it the wrong way
i started it um doing booth rental
instead of commission
and in the business i'm kind of maxed
out at making as much as i can make for
the size so i know i need to expand
but i also know that i have to be taken
serious as a woman and i feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing
to do um and i don't want to do it the
wrong way this time
so i don't really know how to be taken
seriously i'm petite i have blonde hair
i always have crazy fingernails or
sometimes it's purple sometimes it's
blue
yeah so i guess the question would be
where where do i go from where i'm at to
get a lot of attention
i know i i think just got to get a lot
of attention
you know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention
like you have to get people's attention
you guys have to get interesting
so again she doesn't like some of the
things i do
i have to do that i believe in my mind i
have to do some of that
to capture attention whether that's true
or not true
i don't know i don't know maybe it's not
true
you know i know this if somebody wants
to have a movie and it wants to be a
great movie at the theaters they got to
get a lot of attention and get somebody
to go to the movie you got to be willing
to get people not to like you
and what does that look like just by
promoting so much that you irritate
people like what does it mean to get
people not to like
rush limbaugh who's a pretty pretty
divisive guy
uh says uh you know the people that love
him
listen to him two hours a day and the
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so i'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked everybody wants to be the
the popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible
oh i mean i do i'm i'm actually very
very good at my job i just don't know
how to um
take it take it to the next level i
guess maybe maybe i'm scared or i have
money what's your weight
what's your facebook right there nope
the one underneath that
see i don't have a picture of you so i'm
gonna go is that
is that you yes or is that your kids
um that well there's a picture of me and
then it's my daughter
yeah so i mean
i don't want to see your daughter right
now i want to show you right i have a
hair therapy page
um i don't it's under hair therapy yeah
i see hair therapy i see it right here
so like right okay now we got the dogs
yeah but now i'm oh yeah she's a
veterinarian
right so like okay now i got hair okay
that's good
before and after round like like you
guys got to like like get clear on what
the message is right she needs a fa you
need a personal
you need a business page right
the trick is you got to get attention
elena just wrote a book called build an
empire okay
she has to get attention for the book
which means leak out data about the book
not about anything else but that book
what is it what chapter what audio what
am i listening to why am i listening to
it what do i get out of it like constant
pushing
into whatever you do with hair therapy
okay
and it see good good but but dinner date
but what do i do with the dinner date
yeah so see like you
this is where everybody's like when's
enough enough man when do you just enjoy
yourself
i don't know i'm gonna enjoy myself when
i'm in a position to just enjoy myself
people knew me in a particular industry
they didn't know me in every industry
so the first thing that i took on was i
need to get people to know me in every
industry
while i continue to knock on doors and
pay my bills
so if you don't pay your bills you're
not gonna you're so you could
even if you don't pay your bills like
you're gonna die and there's people
around me that needed to eat
so i had to keep knocking on doors spin
that plate
not get stuck in it too much and then
figure out how do i market in brand how
do i build a name nobody knew me 10
years ago you did not know my name
people watching didn't know my name like
people that are coming on the scene now
they're like oh my god that guy he's got
20 you know 14 million people following
and blah blah blah but
you know i started with one follower
just like everybody else and i was the
follower my second follower was my wife
because i created an account for her on
youtube and said you're going to follow
me
it's the same thing on instagram twitter
facebook like
i've grinded for every one of those
followers and delivered content to them
so that i could scale out
you know to
to to to hopefully rather than being
dependent upon one
united states of america hey how do i
get people in australia to know me
how do i get them to want me to come
here how do i get people in
london to want to know me canada south
america oh
i got i got to be in spanish if i'm
going to south america
you know you can't trade in u.s dollars
in mexico
you need to be in pesos come over here
they want to do the aud i'm like i don't
want any of that stuff
just kidding i'll take it all okay so
um so you know you can't keep you got to
keep growing
like facebook is growing you they're
growing
all the possibilities the things they
can do with people so if you want to be
a great business
you you can't you can't
get to a place where you're satisfied
and i had done that i'd gotten satisfied
in my business
externally financially but internally i
wasn't
and it took the economy just getting
slashed that that that finally like okay
i got to change
and build a real business here this is
the problem this is what held me back
for the first
45 years of my life i had a network
that had no net worth
my mama my mama had a hundred thousand
dollars to her name her whole life
after my dad died she was
literally we were in the middle class my
mom was a great mom i'm phenomenal mom
okay
she never overspent but she didn't know
how to earn money right so she was
constantly
trying to save the hundred my network
was basically a bunch of people around
me that were trying to save what they
had
not increase their net worth
okay now there's a lot of ways to get a
net worth you can just go out
you could just go out and get a job
that's one way to get a net worth
i'm gonna go get a job with the right
guy i'm gonna go work at facebook
i'm gonna work around the facebook
people i'm gonna work around the apple
people i'm gonna go work at grant
cardone's place
we got 115 employees over here right now
they said
i want to work for you dude because i
want to be in your environment okay
that's one way number two
go to college if you're going to go to
college go to one of them badass
colleges
where there's a bunch of rich super rich
people
get your freaking priorities straight i
want to be happy go to harvard
and make connections with the obamas in
the bushes
network is your net worth folks networks
do not just happen okay
att's got a network netflix has got a
network google
has a network facebook has a network
americans
have a network republicans have a
network the nra has a network
the democrats have a network they don't
happen
by circumstance you by the way have a
network
you already have an empire the question
is what empire are you going to build
now
ants have empires
and they get crushed by feet
all right so what are you going to do to
build a network i'm going to show you
some things you can do alright you could
get a job you could go to college
college cost you about 40 grand a year
40 to 100 grand a year for a great
college okay the more you pay the better
your network
job a job is going to cost you money to
go to by the way everybody's like hey
what are you going to pay me do jobs
cost money when you take a job a job
cost you money
jobs don't pay you jobs cost you
that doesn't mean a job's a bad thing
you need to go to a job you need
your trading time you're trading time
for a network okay you don't want to
just trade
a job for money you want to trade a job
for opportunity
when johnny the camera guy ryan secco
jared glant when these people came to
work with me guess what
they hooked into my network so when
they're like hey what are you going to
pay me dude i'm going to first thing i'm
gonna pay you is this a connection with
the world
okay as long as you're successful in
this company as long as you show up
as long as you deliver at 10x levels i
will show you off to the world
which does what all of a sudden you're
my guy you're on my team
you're part of 10x nation bang people
that are attracted to me
will be attracted to you your value in
the marketplace goes up
johnny's gotten business because he
works for me his side hustle
has increased his pay has increased on
his
side game because he's connected to
grant cardone
so a job shouldn't just pay you money it
should pay you
you should look like like hey man go
work for facebook don't worry about the
money work
hey i got facebook on my on my on my uh
resume
good and bad because why'd you leave
see working for grant cardone could be
good it can be bad
because when you leave you're gonna have
to tell people i used to work for grant
cardone
yeah what happened
why did big boy get again
it can help you it can hurt you see when
you get close to power dude when you get
close to a fire
it can burn you or it could keep you
warm
so when you guys start thinking about
network i want to be in a network that's
so freaking bright dude
that it could blind me like i got to
wear i got to wear goggles like
everywhere i go
where's my goggles man huh i got to wear
i want to be in a network of people man
where they so
like i mean ballers okay cold stone
billy ballers okay
i want to be like i got to put these on
when i go into the meeting because the
light is so bright the ideas are so big
that i'm tripping the whole time i'm
like i need filters man to protect me
because it's going crazy you know you're
getting a
room with the marks and the bills and
the elons
and oh my god
see that's the kind of network i want
first 45 years of my life man i was in a
network of people
that were limited in their thinking
right so college jobs i could go to
harvard
or mit right some big college i could
give
money to charity i'm showing you guys
how give money to a charity
you walk into the you walk into the make
a wish foundation you say hey i want to
give 10 thousand at an event one night
bang you get moved to the front of the
room
most charities i can walk in i could
give five thousand dollars to a charity
today
and i guarantee they'll put me in the
front table
i wanna be on the front table i want to
be acknowledged okay
so charities okay volunteer if you don't
have any money
then volunteer your time
volunteer your time call bill gates and
melinda and say
i want to volunteer weekends every
weekend for the rest of my life to the
bill and melinda gates foundation
oh my god man i got family grant dude
they can change your network
your family your family is going to
leave you your two little freaking
freeloading kids will leave you
as soon as they get a car
and an offer to work for me i'm out of
here okay let's talk to somebody all
right
because there's another way to play the
game right church you can do a ypo i
think ypos cost 10 grand 10 grand a year
ypos young professionals organization
great connection to people
okay bottom line is there's not one of
these that ain't going to cost you money
you could you could go to an event
everybody does the events by the way you
go to ball games you spend money
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go hang out with
at the dodgers stadium right i'm gonna
be around i'm gonna go to the football
game i'm going to go to see
beyonce and jay-z and everybody in there
smoking weed man
i went and saw j i think i left loaded
just just just from listening to the
music i was like
you know i'm like i don't want to get
high tonight man
so so events like you got to pick your
events though people spend money they
spend
300 to go to a jay-z concert
what do you learn though man you feel
good okay
10x 10x event you want to meet some
freaking ballers
you want to meet some people that are
focused you want to meet some people
that want to blow up
hello mr grant cardone hey hey my friend
how you doing i'm going to ask you a
question can i ask you a question first
sure absolutely go ahead sir okay tell
me the five people
you have spent the most time with in the
last
30 days just give me their names well my
parents my sister sister
my two employees two employees
yes sir and who was the the first person
well my parents you know that's been i'm
a care provider for my parents
okay good good good good so help me out
here hey what do you think your sister's
worth
what have you worked well uh she's got a
good job and
i just bought that just built a brand
new house from scratch you know they
have to rebuild the whole new house
how much is worth uh i know she has a
great
credit score i know that he's 847.
oh she's got worth about a million she's
worth a million dollars
probably yeah because with a house you
know yeah yeah but you can't you can't
include the house in a net worth okay
oh you can't oh well then maybe a
hundred thousand
she's worth okay good what are your two
employees worth
well uh one of them is a really good uh
asset to my uh
shop because she's around the whole shop
and of course she oversees the whole
operation of the i see the operation
myself so what is she worth dude 20
grand
20 grand maybe more than that you're
probably worth to me
is about 50 grand a year 50 grand a year
okay and then what's your parents worth
well they're retired and collect you
know they're collecting you know social
security there
they don't have any assets at all
because they're okay you know this guy
so look look here's the deal this
gentleman what's your name again sir
roberto roberto roberto
in the last 30 days the people he spent
he spent his time around
basically 150 000 worth of five people
his net worth cannot change when you're
surrounded
by people that are thinking small the
i'm not saying these are bad people
his parents have had plenty of time
folks
to get a network and a net worth they're
probably doing the same thing nobody
taught them this
the great hack the great hack on this
planet is this
pay money to change these people that
you're spending time with
okay every week we do a mentoring call
every single day of the week by the way
robert why am i not on your list
well of course you're my uncle uncle g
man
yeah thank you let me ask you this how
much time do you spend with me all week
throughout the week be honest with you i
spent at least two hours a day watching
you on youtube no that's awesome man
that's awesome and then i just got you a
book from uh
cello result i'm reading the only first
about 30 40 pages in
oh that's not i really want to take you
to that february first
convention yeah are you married no sir
i'm single you got a girlfriend
single you got a girl you have a
girlfriend yes dude you know today you
can get you can go to
uh what's the website 10x growthcon dot
com forward slash deal and you can get a
a uh
you can get two seats one for you and
one for your girlfriend for the same
price
and is it 997 i don't i don't know what
it is how much is it guys
yeah it's ridiculous dude it's
ridiculous but again you see why you
guys always ask about the price
no no i'm gonna make sure that i got my
dogs on the road there's a day after my
birthday sorry oh
[ __ ] we're gonna sing you happy birthday
thirty five thousand people thank you so
much
happy birthday to robert
january first i'm doing it right now i'm
doing it how you know you're going to
still be alive then
i don't know i i called you pulling for
me you never know
dude you never know man i want to get my
i want to get that question uncle yeah
go ahead
okay i want a flower shop yeah i've been
in san jose california just over two
years i've known at the shop for a year
and a half
yeah and uh here's what i do i i
specialize in weddings
and i get leads from different
directions all i get most of the time
what all i get is this just their name
and then
their email yeah how do i go about
getting sending a nice email so be a
really nice catchy email so you can
respond back to me
here's our future bride and grooms well
dude look first of all i would not just
focus on weddings
that that's the first piece of advice i
would give you i would never ever be
be dependent upon one vertical correct i
would number two i would look at i would
look one
i think one of the great spaces for you
right now is weekly delivery to homes
and offices there you go okay okay
there's so much money i get i get i
don't even know what i spend on flowers
every week i love flowers
i get new flowers sent to my my home
every week
they do i tell you what can i send you
the sunflowers from here and
on me i wish you would dude i wish you
would by the way he's doing he's doing
networking right now
now he's networking okay the other way
to network with people and get your name
out there is to do business with people
that have high visibility
all right one of the things you want to
do if you want to change your network
is you need to pay pay to play man
okay guys it's called it's called high
visibility
you want to connect with people that
have tremendous visibility
they've already paid the price they're
in the jet stream
once you connect once you pay for
visibility right
once you hook up i spent three months
once with a guy that was worth four
billion dollars
okay cost me money to do that
because you got to spend three months
every day from your job
to spend time with a guy that's worth
for bill by the way
you can get there how do you stay there
okay
you can get to the network how do you
stay in the network networking
will not just happen to you and if it
does just happen to you
it probably won't be good for you a
meridian bank
in the united states hit me today and
said can you share our
st our instagram post i said yeah you do
you know i can't
question is will i and and you know do
you want to know how much it costs
exactly so they they just gave me a loan
for 93 million dollars
they're paying attention to my social
i've raised 200 million 223 million
dollars
in 20 months using instagram and
facebook yeah so
they should be sharing your posts well
they are they are sharing my posts
they want to go the other way right so
you guys out there that are like
should you lean into social listen what
i'm telling you one guy
without a big name no i'm not merrill
lynch raised 223 million dollars in 20
months i paid no fees
what i did pay was the right to be on
instagram
i paid a lot of energy building up an
audience
giving content and delivering content to
that audience
to uh to to a point to where people are
like hey i like what you're saying right
there
i want to give you some money for it i
want to fund your project i want to be
involved with you i want to partner with
you i want to know more right
then i need a landing page boom built a
new business
so that that came out of charity yeah
cardone capital was created out of
charity we i just wanted to educate
people how to
buy real estate and then i realized how
many people were like dude i want to
invest in real estate i don't want to go
do it yeah that's what most people
realize they don't want to do the work
so man social media has been
like everything right it has been um
unbelievable that i could be known in
sydney
and i haven't been here in 20 years like
that is the magic of social media it
does not matter
who you know it matters who knows you um
so i'm going to go up i'm going to go
i'm trying to get to feed you right
okay look i mean i could know some i
could know some people that own places
in fiji
but what if it's already booked they
can't kick them out
but what if people in fiji knew i was
coming
they're like hey mr cardone i want them
calling me i don't want to call them
and so who knows you we're back to the
question who's got my money who's got
your money is who knows you
people do business with people they know
it's how businesses have been done for 2
000 years in this place not people don't
do business with people they trust they
do
but they first do business with people
they know i got to know you
before i trust you and i would rather do
business with somebody i know
and don't trust i do business with
people every day i don't trust
every day i have to don't you think
there's there's an element of
so for example but i know i want to get
this deal i know they can get the deal
done with me right
like the real estate broker i know i'm
not getting quite the truth from him on
this or that but you know what he's got
the deal
i just did two deals i did 120 million
dollars worth of real estate deals with
the same guy
i don't really like him all right but
i'm doing business with him
and and this is not a new thing for
anybody anybody that's not doing
business with people they don't want to
do business with is lying
there's somebody you got people that
work for you you don't like
your network is your net worth how rich
you can get has something to do
with who you're hanging with how rich
you can think has something to do with
who you're hanging with okay how smart
you are
has something to do with your
surroundings if you hang out with dumb
people you will end up dumb
if you hang out with junkies you're
going to end up being a junkie you hang
out with criminals
i'm not talking about the people to go
to jail i'm talking about all the people
at your office right now
they cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with crim crims
you end up being a crim if you want more
money you must change your network
if you want more intelligence you must
change your network if you want more
inspiration you must change your network
your network equals your net worth okay
when i had depression problems it had
something to do with the people i was
hanging out with trust me
when i had depression problems drug
problems
anxiety problems when i had drama in my
life
it was always something to do with my
network
people ask me about networking all the
time they're like hey man how do you get
the right people the five you know
everybody says
hey the five people you spend the most
time with
last night the most time was elena elena
was in the group
sabrina was in the group scarlett was in
the group
i i ran into some cnn news and then i
flipped a fox for a second
that was my network last night
no wonder i was agitated by the time i
went to sleep i got a
six-year-old an eight-year-old cnn and
fox
and i got my wife not listening to me
that's all happened yesterday that was
my network last night
you got to decide to change your network
okay your wife and kids should not be
your primary network
who's in my network who do i want to
meet who are these targets i want to
meet
okay first you got to make a decision a
commitment
to say man i got to add some people to
my network if my network
equals my net worth if that's true then
what would i
do to bring the right people together
i'll tell you what i'll do
i spent four million dollars four
million u.s dollars so that i could get
people to show up
i spent four million dollars to put 9
000 people in a room
so i could spend time with ed mylett
naveen jane
zimmerman jordan zimmerman bradley
uh ezra firestone
les uh tim story tim grover
these guys are all coming for free by
the way i spent
4 million see they don't teach you this
in school man
you guys hold on to your money what
you're doing is you're holding on to
your old money
spending time with your old friends
doing what you're comfortable with and
guess what
you never end up with any new money man
use this money
to buy your network okay this is why i
say man don't stay at holiday ends
don't stay where you can afford stay
where you can create a network ask
yourself this question
have you been hanging out with the same
people your whole life do you have the
same friends that you had when you were
in the third grade
anything changed do your weekends end up
with the same people over and over again
has your income been the same for many
many years now
some of you guys that are in sales you
spend more time with the other
salespeople than you do the customers
when are you going to change your
network you photographers out there
y'all all hang around other
photographers all of them complain about
the same stuff
barbers all complaining about the same
stuff talk about
i oh i got me a new little move
okay when do y'all ever go to another
network
the barbers all go to the barbers the
alcoholics all go to the alcoholics
anonymous
okay everybody stays in their little
freaking network you network marketing
people y'all go to your little network
marketing people
over and over and over again same faces
same people same story same [ __ ]
okay before break i said look man i
spent four million dollars of my money
not to bring nine thousand people
together i spent four million dollars
to bring ed my let see this is what you
guys don't get naveen jane
jordan zimmerman by the way i just got a
phone call from a rod he's like dude i
want to do something with you
he's not even coming to the deal man
because i got these guys
playing he heard about it
okay damon john's coming daymond john's
coming right
russell brunson's coming andy
priscilla's coming what i'm doing is
collaborating to create
a network right what does that do to
grant i don't want this man
i want power man i want influence i want
to be able to change things
i need to grow my network they don't
teach you this in school there's no
school course on this in college the
deal is
where you going to get your job dude the
question is where are you going to build
your network
your network your network is your net
worth okay
okay if i go to harvard there's only one
reason i'm going to harvard
if i go to yale there's only one reason
i'll go to yale
if i go to mit there's only one reason
the information will not be
it okay so when you come to the 10x
growth conference
next week starting thursday when you
guys get there wednesday
you need to get your networking game on
who do you want to meet
who exactly who do you want to meet
otherwise it's going to be a vomit fest
for you you're going to meet a bunch of
people
end up with 900 business cards who do
you want to meet
and what do you want to say to them okay
let's talk to the callers
roy what's going on why by the way the
reason we
we created our mentor group it was why
i want to create my network who's going
to join my mentor group
10x people
who's this dude from where is he from
man
switzerland's in the house see what i
did man i do this show so i can expand
my network
my net worth hey if you guys want any
gold medals
absolutely every day yeah i think you
guys want like you want a skating uh
skating i love your red jackets by the
way they sexy
thank you for that we win gold medals by
making more gold and more medals
let me ask you man do the swiss people
are they are they sometimes a little
angry
uh depends on their bank statement the
banks and the balance that they have on
the account
he says depends on how much money they
have okay what's going on i appreciate
you calling in man
how did you run into me how did you
first run into me
uh i was actually a friend a friend of
mine introduced to you introduced me
with uh your work and since then
um i was i was excited upon hearing your
work and i want to tell you that i'm a
huge fan of your work i read all your
stuff
and i follow you let's say on daily
basis
yeah so you see folks i'm trying to
change my network right so what do i do
i do a show every day why am i doing
that
i'm not doing instagram to watch
instagram i don't do facebook to watch
facebook i do these shows
so i can expand my network and meet
like-minded people okay
what is your question or comment my
friend and thank you for calling in by
the way thank you grant uh well my
question is
very simple i used to work for a company
by myself um
sorry with the company i was doing great
i was doing let's say amazing sales
right now i'm trying to operate my own
marketing business by myself
and i have a lot of difficulties upon
working by myself
i'm i'm trying to be focused on what i'm
doing but
that i i i let a lot of let's say bad
energies
and other things to interrupt me then um
i
i became to be unfocused with my job
yeah
so dude look look you know who do you
meet like on
on the weekends who do you spend time
with on the weekends
well on weekends i'm with my family my
girlfriend my friends
and i'm doing work yeah good okay but
bro
look you got to add some people to your
network man
you're out of balance everybody's like
where's the balance grants where's the
balance
when grant when am i going to spend time
with my family you guys are spending too
much time with your family
familial family comes from familial you
guys are too
familiar with your surroundings and the
stories okay
you need to spend less time with your
family folks
i'm just telling you i know nobody's
gonna find us you got mommy you got
mommy she's already had 27 years man
okay you got daddy okay you got brothers
oh i love my family so much you need
some new family
right to build my clients i'm trying to
improve my work my portfolio
on weekends so i'll be ready for next
week and i always re
uh re-energize my re-energize myself on
weekends so i'll be able to
say to him that's awesome let's say next
week
are you coming to vegas for the
conference
are you coming to vegas for the
conference
absolutely i'm trying to do that yeah
good good well okay so
so look this is what you need to do when
you get there dude you need to make
commit i'm gonna add people to my family
if you guys don't like this network call
it family i like family better
yeah i don't have four family members i
don't have a just a my
my mom died my dad died okay i have an
older brother that's died okay
i got two sisters and a brother if
that's my network i'm done
cause my net my family's going to die
you understand and then i'ma die
so i need to expand my network so people
are talking about me after i'm dead
so i need to add family brothers sisters
i need to add different colored people
different
different ages i need to add i need a
family man it's called mankind we on a
planet
okay the whole planet dude i need
friends in all these places
okay i don't care if it's just the usa
right here i need people over here i
need people
i want i want friends everywhere like oh
my god that's me man
everywhere i go i'm happy because i
gotta network okay
let's talk to the next caller you guys
are gonna be depressed hanging around
the same people all the time
you know all your mama's jokes you know
all your daddy's jokes
you can finish your spouse's oh here he
goes again she rolls her eyes oh
[ __ ] gotta listen to this again you guys
need some new stories man
that's why me and my wife we've moved
five times since we've been married five
different times we're just like pop
let's go some other place now
create a network become real to people
that's why i did this mentoring program
i did this mentoring program so i could
build a network of friends and family i
need to meet a lot of people to meet the
right people
number one commit number two who number
two what you gonna say do not talk about
yourself the whole time
i've created a fund called cardone
capital and it's
changing the way people can invest in
real estate so when i was growing up
and even earl in my early real estate
career i could not
buy the best assets the the best
properties
are left for institutions and banks and
and it's super super wealthy
i'm not talking about i'm done with the
kind of wealth y'all
you're familiar with about and read
about here and i'm not talking about
people that have hundreds of millions
but billions and
hundreds of billions and even trillions
of dollars of available
money to them and so most people
most even real estate professionals get
the leftovers
everything after that and so i've been
playing the real estate game for
30 years and in the last seven years
figured out
okay i'm going to start buying what jp
morgan buys
and blackstone and i'm going to use my
audience
on instagram and facebook and i'm not
going to go get my money from the
institutions
i'm going to get the deal from the
institution and the money is going to
come from my friends
and we're going to crowdsource this
money without paying
brokers the brokers never liked to hear
me say this
but we've raised 300 million dollars
bought a billion dollars worth of real
estate in the last 30 months
i've paid not one penny to a broker wow
so that means all that investor dollars
ends up in the investment
saving the investor money and then we
distribute cash distributions
every single month not every quarter
like the banks distribute every quarter
or
reit a reit will distribute every
quarter it's funny you know people talk
about the power of social media and they
they dis it a lot but last week uh last
week kylie jenner
600 million dollars 51 stake in her
business
you have raised 300 million dollars
through crowdfunding because a lot of
people are wasting time on social media
they're getting likes and comments i
know there's a guy flying into town
tomorrow
and he's big on free and don't monetize
and
and he he's looking at his likes and
comments and i don't look at likes and
comments i look at hey
i have an offer this is what you could
do it's a great deal for you
it's a great deal for me it's a great
deal for everybody that plays and we
want to monetize
so i think i'm going to raise 3 billion
i'm going to create a 10 billion fund
crowd funding and then the banks are
going to come to me and say
we want to buy that thing now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
the world's biggest problem is a lack of
belief that the biggest problem for me
for you for brendan burchard for
everybody is a lack of belief you
believe in yourself to the
extent of what you've done that you can
do it again but you don't believe in the
next step you don't believe that you can
go from here to here
this is why i think everybody has what i
call michael jordan level talent at
something like
you're a genius you are the best in the
world at something
and it's not what what you went to
school for it's not what your parents
taught you it's not what the people
around you are doing it's probably
something very very very different and
unlike
your parents or grandparents it's
actually possible now
because of technology because of the
internet it's actually possible for you
to go off
and be this michael jordan level genius
at something
you don't need to have the resources you
don't need to have the education you
don't need to have
the connection because it's all the
walls have been broken down and it's
only getting easier
but it's still the lack of belief in the
ability to do the thing
people say well i think cancer is the
world's biggest problem great i think
cancer should have been solved by now
the woman who would have solved cancer
is a manager at an accounting firm doing
work that she hates
because one she never believed in
herself enough to
go down the route to become a doctor or
researcher
and two even if she started she didn't
believe in herself enough that she could
be
the genius at it the the michael jordan
level genius best in the world or
something
and this is this is what happens we
settle we get stuck we get complacent we
we find all these reasons and excuses
why we can't do it we're really
it's just fear and lack of belief and
every time you break through every
every major breakthrough that i've had
in my life has come on the other side
of me believing in myself more that i
could go off and do that thing
so even right now i'm working on a
business with brendan uh brendan invited
me
to his place i guess a year ago now in
puerto rico his home
and we've been in touch and
communicating and and what a month ago
or two months ago
he wanted to do a a partnership together
he was like brendan burchard wants to
partner with me on a company this is
great
let's go i wouldn't have believed that
that was possible right
if i look at me five years ago 10 years
ago like there's no way that's going to
happen
and yet here it is happening so how do
you go
and start improving your belief this is
this is i mean it's the ongoing question
this is the the problem that i'm trying
to solve on a daily basis
how do you increase your own or somebody
else's belief
and i don't have all the answers but
i've got two that i think
i try to apply to my life and i think
you can apply to yours
so the first one how do we get more
belief
the first one starts with being around
the people who give you that belief
this is why i have my channel this is
why i make the espresso videos that's
why i do this
every day is because i am trying to give
that to you and i'm trying to get it to
myself
the more i hang around brendan burchard
and oprah winfrey and elon musk and
these people
the more i start to shift the more i
start to see
ooh this is possible when i look at
someone like elon musk and the
and the big ambitions he has every time
i think i'm thinking big i realize man
i'm thinking
small this is nothing compared to what's
possible
i look at les brown who i think is the
greatest speaker of all time
and i see wow that's possible i could do
that right that this is what humans
can't achieve
and so the more that you are staying in
your cocoon
and only hanging around the same five to
ten people if those people are not more
ambitious than you
then you're gonna stay stuck you're
gonna feel good about yourself because
you're pushing everybody and you're
optimistic and and you feel good
relative to where they're at
but you won't be growing you you are
probably the most ambitious person that
you know you
you're the most positive most uplifting
most energetic
most ambitious person of any of the
people that you hang out with and that's
great and fulfilling and
you can serve them and help them but it
limits your own growth
you stay stuck and you stay super slow
growing and so you need to
inject people who have a greater belief
system than you
into your life to make you feel like you
can grow and continue to get better and
that could be somebody who's actually in
your life
quick like side note if there's anybody
in your life
at all who you've met once twice four
times right it doesn't have to be your
family
somebody that you've hung out with and
met that made you feel better about
yourself when you left them
holy cow hang on to that person i love
to what i say collect good people
hang on to those people find a way to to
do a business with them find a way to
spend time with them find a way to
to hang out with them with brendan
burchard reaching out to me to do this
business together right like he's
finding ways
to hang out with what he thinks is good
people so
you know that's that's a tremendous
honor on my part
so if you have anybody like that and
again it's probably not the closest
people to you you have to go on the
fringe of people you have spent some
time with
try to spend more time with them find
the reason to do it whether it's
starting the business together or
whether it's just having
a monthly coffee together just to
connect again do it
if you don't have anybody like that in
your life don't stress that's why
there's videos that's why there's books
that's why there's podcasts if you
watched if you actually started your day
with an espresso video every day
your life will start to shift you won't
notice it tomorrow or the next day or
the next day but
a month later three months later six
months later you're starting to see i'm
i'm thinking bigger now i'm
i'm more bold i'm more confident i want
to do
bigger things with my life well why is
that is because you're hanging around
people who are doing bigger things with
their life even virtually
so i can learn a lot from brendan who
i've met and now doing a
partnership with but also from oprah
winfrey and elon musk and all these
people
the more i'm around them the more they
pull me to want to think bigger
so that has to be part of your daily
routine and ideally in the morning
because if you wake up
and you do the thing that gets you bold
powerful inspired confident
it changes your whole day if you wait
till you're about to go to bed you might
have a hard time sleeping
so better to put it as part of your
morning routine every single day
so that's how you can start to inject
more belief in yourself
be around the people who have a greater
belief system than you
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there